doron de desjardins ça a toujours été de
créer au québec une social démocratie
c'est classe ce que je déplore c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a gardé le projet de
société de la liberté fraternité égalité
on a gardé ça c'est ça notre projet mais
par contre on met en vigueur un système
économique qui produit exactement le
contraire
la justice l'égalité des chances le rôle
social du mouvement desjardins était au
coeur de l'engagement de claude béland
qui est décédé hier à l'âge de 87 ans
claude béland a dirigé des jardins de
1987 à 2000 sous son règne l'institution
s'est modernisé transformé avec
notamment l'introduction du paiement
direct et des transactions en ligne
son objectif était de faire grandir des
jardins tout en demeurant fidèle aux
principes et aux idéaux du mouvement
coopératif
le pdg guy cormier a souligné que grâce
à lui desjardins et près des gens
engagés dans le développement des
régions
il a rappelé aujourd'hui que le monde a
changé et des jardins aussi monsieur bel
air à présider des jardins à une période
où il n'y avait pas d'internet et avait
presque pas d'ordinateur personnes
faisaient affaire sur un téléphone
cellulaire
le monde change aujourd'hui moi je suis
content de voir que monsieur bénin à
travers les notamment les années 90 ont
permis à des jardins de se moderniser a
permis à desjardins s'ouvrir en
travaillant beaucoup plus avec nos
assureurs et knockaërt en faisant
l'acquisition de compagnie de valeurs
mobilières
avec cette expansion le desjardins est
en mesure d'accompagner encore mieux les
québécois québécoise dans l'offre de
services financiers
alban d'amours a été président de
desjardins de 2000 à 2008 bonsoir
monsieur d'amour
bonsoir monsieur médian et c'est
monsieur béland qui vous a embauché
n'est ce pas en 1988 vous l'avez vu à
l'oeuvre dans l'action comment vous
décrivez l'homme son leadership son
approche à bâle homme était chaleureux
son leadership était très enfin il
s'appuyait sur une vision très claire de
du progrès social
il a il a été président des périodes
assez divisés dans l'est
années 90 il faut le rappeler ont débuté
après un ralentissement économique que
il a été du président alors à la au
moment de la reprise économique mais dès
le début des années 90 l'économie c'est
bien sûr a ralenti et là il a été
confronté à des gens j'ai très très
gigean comme celui de la capitalisation
du réseau et des cages
l'enjeu du entourant le modèle de
propriété il a il était intervenu auprès
du législateur qui a permis à des
jardins bien chaud de consolider la
propriété des membres il a fait face à
des gens je de rentabilité au milieu des
années 90 et avec l'avènement d'internet
et il a il a donc été au coeur de
beaucoup de problématiques de l'époque
et de transformation de changement
comment il voyait ces changements là
est-ce que celle l'inquiétait est ce
qu'il voulait aller au pot de vin est ce
qu'ils les comprenez bien comme comment
il vivait ça là il disait il et vivait
bien mais d'un jeu pourra dire que ça a
été une époque difficile et ses rapports
avec les fédérations dans un contexte où
le partage des responsabilités était mal
définie il sentait bien qu'il fallait
regrouper les fédérations et la
confédération de manière à la rendre
arrange le mouvement plus efficace et
dans ce contexte là il ay nous enseigner
par exemple que le changement était
nécessaire et que pour assurer l'avenir
du mouvement des caisses desjardins
il fallait aller vers le changement et à
exercer un leadership considérable
auprès des dirigeants de desjardins pour
les amener à conclure
l'inévitable savoir qu'il fallait se
regrouper pour être plus fort mais ce
chiffre ce changement monsieur d'amour
il le voyait pour perpétuer l'oeuvre de
desjardins plus que pour l'expansion de
desjardins est ce que j'ai raison des
dire ça comme ça
les deux des deux là il doit aller 2
il avait de grandes ambitions pour le
mouvement les jardins par exemple le
fait qu'il ait voulu rallier toutes les
15 secondes
le canadienne desjardins au nouveau
brunswick car manitoba en ontario
il appelle ses proches essayé rapproche
par là qu'ils ont donnée non porté fruit
et il avait aussi cette préoccupation
majeure d'assurer la pérennité de
desjardins nous et il vient sur tout les
problèmes de rentabilité tous ces
problèmes là l'aube parfois rendu sa
tâche bien difficile parce que il a
fallu aller vers le regroupement des
caisses par exemple est ce que c'est
être contre son gré au début des années
90 il ne favorisait pas le regroupement
des caisses parce que eddy voyait une
perte d' aide au niveau de la démocratie
à perdre deux dirigeants mais rapidement
en cours ou cours des années j'ai rendu
compte qu'un il fallait il fallait
regrouper des cages parce que les
membres exiger plus de compétences à la
part des caisses et cette expertise on
l'a obtenue on l'a développé un
regroupant des experts des cages on a on
a imagé laquais de demain vous l'avez
souligné
internet est arrivé les cartes de débit
aussi se sont installés et sa modifié le
modèle d'affaires de desjardins et donc
on est entré aussi il accepter en
quelque sorte de d'entrer dans le jeu de
la concurrence même si déjà des jardins
en concurrence avec les banques mais une
concurrence plus fort mais critiquée en
même temps beaucoup le modèle bancaire
la recherche de profits avant tout
pourquoi il n'avait pas le choix de
faire le virage concurrentiel selon vous
à il n'avait pas le choix
dès le début des années lorsque la loi
des banques a été amendé est la fin d
année
soixante et soixante dix où le débit
johnny chan un juge desjardins gea a
vécu le choc du futur
il s'est vu lens est propulsé dans un
environnement concurrentiel très
exigeant alors et monsieur béland a été
au coeur de tout développement là et ils
étaient très conscients du fait que
cette concurrence là il fallait
l'affronter mais gageure avec une
conscience très développés du fait que
l'argent devait être toujours observé
chez des hommes et que la société bien
aller profiter de la présence du modèle
coopératif comme un contrepoids au
modèle dominant les valeurs coopératives
bien sûr j'aime eu l'air de partage
chan ho cho de capital un capital qui
est n'a pas n'a pas le pouvoir dans le
jardin chez la personne quels pouvoirs
jeudi ce coup là il détenait d'une
sachant passionné mais en étant très
convaincante et il a été dans les
dernières années vous l'avez entendu
comme moi critique quand même à l'égard
de desjardins dans les dernières années
il affirmait que desjardins était
désormais fait pour les riches
est-ce que vous avez discuté de cela
avec lui de ce que devenait desjardins
au fil du temps oui j'en ai discuté avec
lui et m j'essaie de le conforter dans
et faire en sorte que ça son anxiété par
rapport à ça fait serein lors en moins
malheureux parce que déjà dans il
fallait il fallait voir évoluer le
jardin il fallait qu'il se développe
qu'il fallait qu'ils changent c'est
lui-même qui nous avaient évité aux
changements qui nous avait évoqué à cet
égard là et les membres desjardins ont
bien accueilli le changement parce que
ce changement était destiné à répondre à
leurs besoins mais dans un nouvel
environnement technologique et dans ce
contexte là desjardins est ce que je
discutais souvent avec lui c'est de
contenu en fait que desjardins ne
perdait pas son âme
même si dans nos pratiques commerciales
parfois on met à risque que notre
logique d'affaires
nous sommes très préoccupés gelée était
à titre de président et les présidents
qui m'ont suivi vrai loin ont vu cette
préoccupation faire en sorte cette
logique de service domaine sur la
logique que de profits monsieur d'amour
merci d'avoir pris ce temps avec nous ce
soir pour rendre hommage à claude béland
ça me fait plaisir le gers il y en aura
dix et la société qui me qui m'intéresse
est-ce qu'on va bâtir une société
meilleure
avec le système actuel avec ce qui se
passe actuellement
comment comment est de ceux-là en
encourageant le même système en
permettant les paradis fiscaux
et comment voulez vous que la population
ne réagissent pas avec un peu de d'orage
ou un peu de colère
[Musique]